[Music]
[Applause]
one of the great Shooters in NBA history
ESPN NBA analyst Tim legler joining us
on the show I'll save my bombshell
question for you
I gotta get to the Celtics last night
against the Miami Heat and why do I get
the feeling this is going to go seven
games Tim
laughs
I'm actually kind of feeling that a
little bit myself uh and it you know you
heard the Celtics say don't let us get
one basically they were warning the heat
now don't let us mess around and figure
this thing out because then you got a
problem on your hands because we were
the two seed and four are probably the
first two and a half months of the
season they were clearly the best team
in the NBA so it's there they've had a
hard time finding it consistently uh
since that time and certainly in the
playoffs they've had some very flat
performances but now you really do feel
like they're going to win game five
I don't know if it's going to get all
the way to seven Dan I can see the Heat
winning this in six games okay and get
and getting very dicey like a fourth
quarter one possession game in a game
six
um and I and you know Jimmy Butler
probably making some plays in that game
to win it late but there's no doubt that
things have gotten much more interesting
all of a sudden
uh you've been around the game a long
long time and there are certain players
that they play bigger better the bigger
the game maybe during the regular season
we don't talk about Jimmy Butler during
the regular season but we certainly do
the postseason Reggie Miller was another
player who got 18 or 19 a game and then
in the postseason could go off can you
think of other players who have that
ability to be big in big games
yeah I mean I think there's you know
even a guy I'd look at even a guy like
Jamal Murray you know as one of those
guys he seems to
relish that moment and actually there's
something different about him even this
year he looks like he's ticked off
because every night he takes to court we
know you know we're going to talk a lot
about jokic obviously every team they
play for the most part probably has two
stars on it
and we talk a lot about the stars in the
game and I think Jamal Murray takes that
personally in in the Phoenix series he's
out there and saying okay you got KD we
got jokic we know what those guys are
and then Devin Booker is getting so much
love and deservedly so the guy was
playing out of his mind but I'm on that
level and I think he's had this sort of
edge to him every night that bodes well
for Denver because in the regular season
Jamal Murray is a very good player Jamal
Murray can be Sensational in big moments
in the postseason so I think for in
terms of guys currently in the league
he'd be a good example but what is it
about Jimmy Butler that makes other
teams nervous
well here's the thing they know for a
fact Jimmy Butler is always going to be
in the right right place mentally like
at no point is Jimmy Butler's confidence
gonna wait waiver is he gonna be a guy
that just doesn't have it on a given
night Jimmy Butler's the kind of guy
you're gonna have to kill him to stop
him and you know he's so mentally tough
that no matter what the moment or the
circumstances or the amount of pressure
Jimmy Butler is not going to be shaken
by that and some guys they look like
they lose their confidence a little bit
they change their aggressiveness they're
not quite the same for whatever reason
Jimmy Butler's never like that even
though Knights who doesn't mean he's
gonna shoot well every night some nights
he might just not shoot well you know
it's not because he's feeling the moment
or anything's a little bit too big for
him and I think that's why teams get
nervous about him and also he can get to
anywhere on the floor that he needs to
to play to his wheelhouse he can get to
that mid-range area of the floor anytime
he wants Tim legler ESPN NBA analyst
joining us on the program the change or
changes you would make to the Lakers
roster in the off season
oh man this well first of all they're
going to have to I think they need to
add guys that are more consistent
Shooters and if you sacrifice a little
bit defensively to do that I think it's
important because first of all the
league is not set up anymore to be a
league that you can Maul people and get
physical and just get into teams and
defend them you're going to have to get
to a certain number most nights and when
you look at the Western Conference in
particular what Denver's can do every
night offensively with Phoenix you know
that they're going to reload you know
what those teams are getting to 100 1520
points regularly so can you get to that
number so all the great defense that we
talked about a lot with the Lakers and
being this long team and they're
athletic and they're going to be able to
bother Denver got news for you Denver
shot splits of basically 50 40 80 as a
team
okay so as an individual player for
people listening if you go 50 from the
field 40 from the 3 80 from the line
I did that I did that a couple of times
I was a 50 50 80 guy a couple of times
right that's a hell of a year or a hell
of a series if one guy does that imagine
a whole team doing that and that's what
they just did to the Lakers that's how
efficient they were so the Lakers need
to add shooting I think as their top
priority look Kyrie this talk is going
to be there all summer
I'm not a Kyrie Irving guy I think he
brings an awful lot to a team that not
necessarily going to move you in the
right direction the talent's undeniable
but this might be the one situation I'd
say that team probably needs a guy like
Kyrie Irving and LeBron probably these
career what did you make of LeBron's
post-game comments
I heard you're setting this up saying
you know he needs a hug I thought that
maybe last because when I'm watching it
what I'm thinking is this I don't care
if it's LeBron James or any athlete or
any person in any Walk of Life that you
just towards your heart and soul into
something for eight months and it ends
in a terribly frustrating manner you
feel almost inept against the team that
beat you
that's not the right time to get asked
the question it's certainly not the
right time to answer a question like
that because in the moment you feel
nothing other than I just want to get
away from the damn game right now and
and he's gonna go and it's going to be
more frustrating for the next two weeks
to watch the finals he's not
participating
now let it get removed a few weeks from
that now he's gone on vacation he spent
time with his family he's back in the
gym a little bit his body feels great
after getting a month off for the
regular season he's going to have a
completely different tune when you get
to the middle of July there is
absolutely no question in my mind LeBron
James isn't going anywhere and you know
and even the brawny thing we build that
up I don't know how much that's what is
going to drive him to continue to play I
just don't think he wants to go out the
way he just went out more than anything
else
he doesn't want to end on that note so
he's going to I think reload his mind
get his body feeling better and you're
going to see LeBron James ready to go
next year I was serious when I said he
needs a hug because then he's saying I'm
better than 90 of the player like you
don't need to say that right like we'll
say that for you we don't you know he
doesn't need to and it's almost like he
he wanted somebody to kind of just boost
his spirits or his ego or a little bit
because he just got swept yeah I think
that's fair I mean guys need that right
they need to be Strokes guys on that
level that ironically I think he
actually shortchanged himself he's
probably it's probably more like 97 of
the guys in the league he's still better
then but yeah I think he needed a little
bit of you know a little validation in
that moment because they just got swept
by a team that's got right now the best
player in the NBA
it was interesting though the one thing
that was is interesting Dan and hearing
him say that that percentage whatever
and whatever you want to say he could
have said 99
and what is he what is he really saying
he's not necessarily the best player
anymore and I think that's the first
time that LeBron James has ever sort of
acknowledged that and when you get swept
by a team that has the best player in
the league on it it sort of reminds you
of that in the moment that they're going
to need more help it used to be LeBron
would say hey I'll take whatever you got
and I'll take my chances now I think he
realizes that there are teams out there
that are going to be loaded that he's
going to need a little bit more to
compete with would you consider trading
Anthony Davis
I would definitely consider trading
Anthony Davis there's no question in my
mind I think everybody around the league
is going to feel the same way about
Anthony Davis that we do every night
watching him and analyzing him you know
the guys the Difference Maker clearly
there's no real matchup for Anthony
Davis there's not an answer for him he's
a total Game Changer defensively when
he's when he's active but do you want to
sign up for that and like guarantee that
you're going to get like 50 games of
that every year and in the postseason
you'll get it you know more than
probably every other night that's
probably selling him a little bit short
but let's say you get it 65 percent of
the time in the postseason and he's your
second best player is that enough are
you going to be happy with that so I
just wonder first what people would
genuinely be willing to give up for
Anthony Davis knowing at some point he's
going to miss a large chunk of time in
the regular season for an injury and
then you're not exactly sure if he's
going to leave his house every day in
the playoffs intent on coming to the
arena and doing some serious damage
because I don't know that he always gets
himself there mentally
I was looking for a comp we love to have
comps with players like that guy reminds
me of and I was thinking about Joker and
Brad Daugherty
I don't know if that's a fair comp but
just the ability to play high low in out
pass Dougherty I always thought was one
of the more underrated players that uh I
saw a play but you got to comp for uh
jokic
I don't have a cop for him because I and
I think about this all the time usually
pretty good at coming up with that and
I've been asked this question
and I've racked my brain and I'm also
kind of like a historian of the game and
I'm old enough that I know all the
errors
he's so unique in that I was thinking
about this last night as I get ready to
to break down the finals whenever they
get their matchup I don't care who comes
out of the East Denver is going to win
the championship and the reason is
because there's no Personnel scheme
or defensive energy
amount of defensive energy that affects
jokic he's not affected by it you put a
smaller guy on him that's athletic he
makes those guys look silly because he
just overwhelms them with his size and
touch you put a bigger guy on him well
now you got to chase them all over the
perimeter while he runs 87 dribble
handoffs and picks and pops and
and spend so much time on the perimeter
that he makes Bigs like a fish out of
water out there guarding him so much you
can't scheme him because you can't
double him effectively anywhere on the
floor because of his size and his mind
in Reading where the ball should go and
then getting it there with velocity
so it beats the defense it beats the
close out of Beats the rotation so
there's not a matchup that you can come
up with even nights when he doesn't
shoot well those are rare because he
shoots such a high percentage he does
have nights like that and he's still the
most dominant player on the floor he's
controlling the game to such an extent
and I can't think of another player his
size particularly that can do all of the
things that he can do
all right I'll leave you with this
will the Lakers retire LeBron James's
number
oh no question no question and I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that they
shouldn't but I'm just saying the
standard for getting your jersey retired
has been dramatically diminished okay
it's a pretty saturated Jersey
retirement these are the Lakers though
legs that doesn't mean yeah I know
they're the Lakers but that's LeBron
James you had a guy that
in my opinion I think probably yours I
don't know you put you put LeBron number
two cemented at number two all time yeah
yeah so do I and I think
hate to say it for him but I think he
could win two or three more
championships I probably still have him
cemented at number two that he can't
that's why when we were talking about
the LeBron Curry matchup like who can
help their legacy more yeah I said well
LeBron James has been like you know he's
been like Flex sealed into the number
two spot right like he can't you can't
move it I don't think there's any upward
mobility and he's not getting caught
from behind at least not by anybody we
can see right now Curry he's still
grabbing rungs on the ladder I feel like
which is pretty amazing at this stage
career so I just feel like LeBron
cemented at number two he wore a Lakers
jersey you had that guy in-house for
however many years it's going to be was
it been four years now
how many years is LeBron you're five oh
you're five okay let's say you play
seven years for the league okay and he
won a championship there right and even
if he never gets another win and he's
the second greatest player to ever play
that thing's going up there there's no
question in my mind well it is Hollywood
and they celebrate their Stars so I
understand that you would want to have a
night for LeBron when it's all said and
done I get that I'm just it it just
feels like you know the Laker fans don't
look at LeBron as one of them like he's
not a true Laker and and I understand
that and he did give you a championship
I just don't know my feeling is that
there would probably be pushback of is
you know does he deserve to be in the
rafters
were you talking about pushback from the
fan base yeah well that that I mean that
might be true but I think ultimately the
organization is going to want to do that
because you never even know they might
have aspirations down the road of having
a guy with you know LeBron's mind and
and in your front office or part of the
organization oh he's gonna get his own
team he's going to get it yeah he'll get
the team in Vegas
that's probably true it's probably what
but he'll end up doing or maybe he takes
over Jordan's team in Carolina
yeah that would be something
and then maybe maybe he's thinking I'll
buy this I'll buy Charlotte yeah and
then I'll win a championship in
Charlotte that might be the one way I
can I can still plant Michael that would
be it that's being the greatest of all
time good to visit with you as always
legs thanks for joining us one of the
great Shooters in NBA history Tim legler
their ESPN analyst so is that a is that
a bombshell is that a social media
question should the Lakers or will the
Lakers retire LeBron's Jersey